>>> IN RUSSIA, HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF MEN, WOULD-BE CON
SCRIPTEES ARE ON THE RUN.
THEY'VE BEEN ABANDONING THEIR
HOME AND IN SOME CASES THEIR
FAMILIES IN ORDER TO AVOID
FIGHTING A WAR AGAINST UKRAINE
THEY DO NOT SUPPORT.
IN KAZAKHSTAN OVER 200,000
RUSSIANS HAVE ARRIVED JUST THIS
WEEK LOOKING FOR REFUGE.
>> Reporter: RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S ORDER
CONSCRIPTING MEN TO FIGHT IN THE
WAR HAS CREATED DRAFT DODGERS.
THEY LINE UP DAILY IN
NEIGHBORING KAZAKHSTAN TO
REGISTER WITH LOCAL AUTHORITIES.
THE GOVERNMENT SAYS MORE THAN
200,000 RUSSIANS FLED TO THIS
COUNTRY IN LESS THAN TWO WEEKS.
>> YES, WE RAN AWAY FROM RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: THEY FLED MOSCOW
LAST WEEK TO ESCAPE THE DRAFT.
>> WE DON'T WANT THIS WAR AND WE
DON'T RECOGNIZE THE POSITION OF
OUR GOVERNMENT.
>> Reporter: MANY OF RUSSIA'S
LAND BORDERS CHOKED FOR WEEKS
WITH LONG LINES, AS CITIZENS RUN
FOR THE EXITS.
DRAFT DODGERS TRAVELING BY LAND
WAIT DAYS IN LINE OR PAY BIG
MONEY FOR SCARCE PLANE TICKETS
TO ESCAPE.
AND THAT'S JUST THE FIRST STEP.
EVERYDAY MORE RUSSIANS ARRIVE AT
THIS TRAIN STATION WITH THEIR
BACKPACKS AND ALL SAY THE SAME
THING, THEY WERE AFRAID THEY
COULD BE SENT TO FIGHT IN
UKRAINE AND THEY ABANDONED THEIR
COUNTRY ON SHORT NOTICE.
>> THIS COUPLE LEFT TOGETHER.
>> DID YOU COME BECAUSE OF THE
MOBILIZATION FOR THE WAR IN
UKRAINE?
>> IT WAS THE FINAL KICK FOR OUR
JOURNEY, I GUESS.
>> WERE YOU AFRAID THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE TO GO FIGHT IN THE
WAR?
>> YEAH.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING I WANT TO
PARTICIPATE IN.
>> Reporter: THE FLOOD OF NEW
ARRIVALS SURPRISING LOCAL
BUSINESS OWNERS, LIKE THIS ONE
IN THE CENTER OF TOWN.
>> THIS GENTLEMAN JUST WALKED
IN.
IS THIS UNUSUAL?
>> VERY UNUSUAL.
EVERYDAY IS LIKE THIS.
THEY COME WITH HUGE SUITCASES
AND THEY COME IN HERE FOR
WORKING AND SITTING AND LOOKING
FOR SOME A ACCOMMODATION.
>> THESE ARE FRESH ARRIVALS FROM
RUSSIA?
>> YES.
>> ARRIVING WITH A BACKPACK ON
THEIR BACK.
>> Reporter: IN THE CITY
HUNDREDS OF MILES FROM THE
RUSSIAN BORDER, I SPOKE WITH
DOZENS OF NEWLY ARRIVED
RUSSIANS, RANGING FROM
DOCTORS --
>> IF WE REFUSE TO GO TO THIS
WAR, WE SHOULD GO TO THE JAIL.
>> Reporter: -- TO ENGINEERS,
I.T. SPECIALISTS AND UNIVERSITY
STUDENTS.
>> YOU RAN AWAY FROM RUSSIA?
>> YEAH, FROM MOBILIZATION, FROM
MILITARY SERVICE.
>> Reporter: MOST DON'T WANT TO
BE IDENTIFIED TO PROTECT LOVED
ONES STILL IN RUSSIA.
>> HOW CAN I TAKE PART IN THE
WAR WITHOUT A WISH TO WIN THIS
WAR?
>> Reporter: THIS MAN SAYS
PUTIN'S DRAFT LEFT HIM NO OTHER
CHOICE BUT TO FLEE THE COUNTRY,
LEAVING HIS WIFE AND CHILD
BEHIND.
>> WE DO NOT TRUST OUR
GOVERNMENT.
WE DON'T BELIEVE IN WHAT THEY
SAY.
>> Reporter: HE SAYS A RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT CRACKDOWN ON DISSENT
HAS MADE PROTESTING FUTILE,
LEAVING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
MEN SUDDENLY ADRIFT, TRYING TO
FIND WORK AND ACCOMMODATION IN
FOREIGN COUNTRIES.
>> I AM THE CITIZEN OF THE
COUNTRY THAT STARTED THE WAR.
I DID NOT SUPPORT THIS WAR,
NEVER DID.
BUT SOMEHOW I'M STILL CONNECTED
BECAUSE OF MY PASSPORT, AND I AM
AT THE SAME TIME A REFUGEE.
>> Reporter: RUSSIANS ON THE RUN
SHARING A COLLECTIVE SENSE OF
HOPELESSNESS AND GUILT OVER THE
DESTRUCTION CAUSED BY THEIR
GOVERNMENT.
JAKE, IT'S NOT JUST INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE FLEEING.
I'M HEARING FROM RUSSIANS THAT
I'M TALKING TO HERE THAT THEY'RE
SAYING THAT THEIR BOSSES HAVE
BEEN SENDING THEM ACROSS BORDER,
THAT IN SOME CASES THIS APPEARS
TO BE THE CORPORATE POLICY OF
SOME RUSSIAN COMPANIES, TO SEND
THEIR EMPLOYEES OUT TO ALSO HELP
THEM ESCAPE THE DRAFT.
AND ALL OF THIS SHOWS US THAT
THERE IS SOME SERIOUS LACK OF
FAITH AND CREDIBILITY IN THE
CURRENT POLICIES, THE WAR
POLICIES OF THE KREMLIN.
>> ALL RIGHT, IVAN WATSON IN
KAZAKHSTAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>>> HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
RUSSIANS ARE BEGINNING TO SEEK
ASYLUM.
EARLIER THIS WEEK TWO RUSSIAN
MEN ARRIVED BY BOAT IN ALASKA.
THEY APPARENTLY DEPARTED FROM
RUSSIA, CROSSED THE STRAIT AND
LANDED ON ALASKA'S ST. LAWRENCE
ISLAND.
THE MEN WERE TRANSPORTED TO
ANCHORAGE TO BE PROCESSED.
THEY'RE ASKING TO STAY IN THE
UNITED STATES IN HOPES OF
AVOIDING COMPULSORY MILITARY
SERVICE.
THE EMBASSY IS PLA